all right let's jump into this first
story from timcast.com Tulsi gabbard
quits Democratic party citing wokeness
and anti-white racism calls the party
existential threat to America and urges
other party members to join her that's
the gist of the story she gave a speech
saying nonetheless I can no longer
remain in today's Democratic party it's
now under the complete control of an
elitist cabal of War mongers driven by
cowardly wokeness who divide Us by
racializing every issue in stoking
anti-white racism who actively worked to
undermine our god-given freedoms and
shrined in our Constitution and who are
hostile to people of faith and
spirituality who demonize the police who
who protect criminals at the expense of
the law
well that's good news as far as I'm
concerned but I do think she should have
come out and stated this a long time ago
absolutely right I mean finally welcome
to the nightmare that the overwhelming
majority of us have been living for you
know for quite some time probably on
steroids since 2016. so you know I don't
know a little too late I don't know but
I do believe that it is indicative of
what will happen to the Democrat Party I
think more and more you will see a lot
of people sane reasonable people who are
waking up to the reality of uh what the
left how the left has taken over the
Democrat Party this is one of the
craziest things that I've been hearing a
lot of behind the scenes that
something's been happening recently
where people are snapping and there's
like Mass red pilling going on I'm
hearing stories of like
you know from friends and this is not
like celebrities or famous people just
like hey my friend was all of a sudden
one day just came to me and said that
you know what's going on with war what's
going on with World War III Joe Biden's
doing all this and people are going from
in the dark to Red Pill just like very
very quickly and I I wonder if a lot of
it is when the news says nuclear war may
be coming you start to pay attention and
then when you do you go hey wait a
minute this Biden guy is actually really
bad I don't know if it's nuclear war I
think it's gas prices I think it's too
shortages that's a good point I think
it's those things for a lot of people I
live in a very woke quote-unquote uh
kind of area right outside of
Philadelphia the second uh the third
largest county in the state of
Pennsylvania the second wealthiest
county in the state of Pennsylvania
these people are very woke
um but however when you look at a lot of
these people are beginning to take that
red pill that they're watching what
happened to their children I think
education is going to be a really really
big issue for a lot of those Suburban
moms I was thinking that covid the
lockdowns or the shutdowns rather and
then the riots that didn't have much of
a military response or police response
was kind of opening but I think you're
right that it's gas prices
yeah I think you know my perspective is
like why would a young person and then
you know obviously the war is that's
probably my personal bias you bring up
gas prices and I'm like oh yeah yeah
you're probably right some some uh you
know minimum wage skateboarder guy who's
trying to get enough gas mustered up to
go to the skate park is probably saying
what the is going on yeah and then he's
looking it up and being like why did
Biden shut down the Keystone Pipeline
yeah I guess I personally think it's the
great reset I personally think it's the
build back better agenda which coalesces
into all of these things when it comes
to not only actively being a war Monger
but also destroying the economy which I
think is being done deliberately here
here but but to go back into this topic
it does seem like the Democratic
establishment party is a sinking ship
they're expected to to lose a lot of
seats in this upcoming election and if
we remember Tulsi gabbard she was she
was seen as a rising star a few years
ago until she questioned the Syrian War
until she actually said hey maybe we
shouldn't be warmongers maybe we
shouldn't do regime change maybe we
shouldn't be financing Isis and Al Qaeda
inside of the Middle East and launching
a war on terror which of course is being
financed by our own money and when she
pushed back against a lot of the war
policies that's when the bigger attacks
against her happened by her own party
sort of it was really when she came out
against Hillary Clinton yeah that was
when the machine went yeah yeah but she
was again she was the first combat
veteran female running for president of
the United States you would think just
basically on those merits that the
Democratic party would lose their mind
and overwhelmingly illegal support no
absolutely not they didn't believe in
her they questioned her they called her
a Russian asset they criticized her
every step of the way because she dared
to say hey hey you know know all these
lies all these bigger Banker bailouts
all the ways that you're being screwed
over in America is not okay and I'm
going to stand up against it she did
successfully her her Smackdown of Kamala
Harris is absolutely epic and she has
done a lot of good when it came to
pushing the Overton window starting
conversations and debates even though
she was anti-gun endorsed Joe Biden in
the world economics nuclear power and
the world economic Forum even liked her
so much that they put up put her up as
as Representatives now she of course
along with
um
Dan Crenshaw say that they were put on
there it would out there kind of consent
but but regardless still the world
economic Forum said hey this is a good
person we like we want to promote she
endorsed Joe Biden yeah I'm in luck how
are you going to come out and say the
party's been taken over by a cabal of
warmongers when you endorsed one of the
principal warmongers don't tell me Tulsi
didn't know about what Joe Biden was
doing in the early in in the early 2010s
with the Iraq War his brother is getting
these lucrative contracts she like
there's no way she is unaware of what
Hunter Biden was accused of doing with
the laptop stuff so I can I can respect
if you know behind the scenes she's
trying to be tactful and try and still
remain in the Democratic party to try
and bring people into it who might
actually be sane as to and cognizant of
what's going on but I kind of just feel
like it's 2022. we're two months out not
barely from uh just just about two
months out from the from 2023 and Tulsi
is coming out saying I'm quitting the
Democratic party and it's just like yo
if you came out in October of 2020 and
said all of this exact same stuff like I
will not endorse a warmonger like Joe
Biden we may have gotten Donald Trump
and we would not be at War right now
yeah and she's also a member of the
counts on Foreign Relations which should
spark up a lot of eyebrows but uh
there's a lot of other scuttlebutt
behind the scenes talking about her
potentially joining Donald Trump her
potentially joining DeSantis and running
with them for these upcoming uh
presidential elections so there's a lot
of scuttlebutt about her positioning
herself to be more politically relevant
and be able to run on a party ticket
that would Galvanize a lot of the
Working Class People because but at the
end of the day even though you know
World economic Forum endorsed to see a
farm member and endorsed Joe Biden
anti-gun she still does talk about a lot
of important issues that do uh push the
Overton window that do start
conversations that I think are important
all right I'm gonna say this everybody
deserves to evolve even you know Jack
Huger of The Young Turks he supported
defunding police today he says it's a
losing idea and it's a bad idea and he's
right and I and I commend commend him
for realizing the mistake he made
previously and now coming out saying you
know what defund the place is a bad idea
I still think it's important to point
out Tulsi gabbard was very very wrong in
2020. in this article from NBC News and
uh Tulsi gabbard ends presidential run
endorses Biden she said it's clear that
Democratic primary voters have chosen
Vice President Joe Biden to be that per
to be the person who will take on
President Trump in the general election
I'm confident that he will lead our
country Guided by the spirit of Aloha
respect and compassion and thus help
heal the divisiveness that has been
tearing our country apart
uh an announcement she noted that you
continue her military service but uh
anyway to go back to that quote she was
wrong Joe Biden has has and that speech
where he came out and called Maga
Republicans an existential threat to
this country did the exact opposite so
this is just Tulsi being very very very
wrong
and if she came out back then and said
Joe Biden is divisive Joe Biden is a
threat to this country and we should not
be supporting him she didn't she
wouldn't even have to come out and
endorse Trump she can just be like I
will not endorse a man who was who is
vice president to Administration that
blew up children in the Middle East and
for what reason couldn't tell you War
Empire regime change she'd probably just
say regime change but respectable
instead she actually and this blew my
mind endorsed Joe Biden while
campaigning on ending regime change War
it's like what do you think the Obama
Administration was doing with Joe Biden
there as vice president and now here we
are closer to war than ever so go ahead
no no but that's what's expected right
once you are once you are not going to
win a particular race then the party
expects you to just line up and do as
you're told just take one for the team
and A lot of people do that without uh
of just doing what others expect them to
do I find it to be very inauthentic and
authenticity was you know a huge part of
it was something that I was very
intentional about at the very beginning
of my race is to remain true to those
values that brought me into the
Republican party when I was a junior in
college from the Democrat Party to be
authentic to those values that will
cause me to want to run in the first
place because I earnestly believe we're
about to lose our country I don't
believe that that's hyperbole I believe
things are have gone very wrong and we
need something very different so for her
to come out and support uh Joe Biden in
2020 that is what is expected of people
and you know and and and to be
completely honest that's what plastic
politicians do you get dragged through
the mud but then once it's all over
everyone expects you to shut up line up
do as you're told and just go on but I
wanted to go back to something you said
earlier about you know the fact that uh
you know that she's a woman she's this
she's that she checks off all the boxes
the Democrat Party should have been in
love with her uh that only works if you
also uh Follow The Narrative but if you
have your own mind your own thoughts and
your own opinion I don't care how many
boxes you check off I mean look at me
I'm black I'm a woman I grew up dirt
poor on a pig farm in Southern Alabama
underneath a rock you would think the
Republican Party the Democrat Party
would be like we love her you would
think that Republican establishment
would be like praise the Lord now we
have a fighting chance to stoke some
enthusiasm in our party but if you don't
follow the narrative
and the script it doesn't matter how
many boxes you check off they don't want
to have anything to do with it yeah but
put it simply if you're not a controlled
puppet you're not going to get any play
and support by The Establishment but I
also want them either side I wanted to
ask you in Hollywood with your permians
your understanding of politics do you
think this move is highlighting maybe
something bigger maybe a bigger move
between a potential 2024 run do you
think something's happening behind the
scenes what do you think Tulsi is doing
here no one does anything in this
industry because it's the right thing to
do
if you think people in this industry do
things because it's the right thing to
do solely because it's the right thing
to do
that's not how this works yeah I don't
want to call it a publicity stunt but
she she coincided this uh announcement
with the announcement of her new show
the Tulsa show and on episode I'm not
sure I think it's on YouTube and okay
and uh an episode of Joe Rogan's podcast
that she just went on I just saw an ad
for that today so this was very planned
that she's probably been thinking about
this for a long time but she has been
taking you know little red pills at the
little red pills at the little red pills
for some time now right um now I don't
believe now a lot of Republicans we get
excited when people throw us little
bones
um you know oh look she's moving to our
side so I never thought she was a
conservative or really a republican but
I have seen over some period of time of
her taking these little red pills and so
now she finally took enough of them
where she's saying I'm leaving the
Democrat Party I think I think that's
going to be endemic of what we see
happen across a lot of uh you know those
particular communities where Democrats
have basically have taken people for
granted their vote for granted other
than the black community I think the
black community would probably be the
very last people to come off the
Democrat Plantation I think you're going
to see more and more Hispanics leave the
Democrat Party I think we're already
experiencing that thanks for checking
out this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there